and i think symbolically at the very end
of our lives if we can still say you
know we were never humbled we were
knocked down but we got up and i can say
i lived life with integrity and i took
all the blows and i still prevailed i
think that's a good epitaph for anyone i
also realized that you can't be alone
to really succeed no man really is an
island and i think
personally speaking that's happened to
me too when when you find the right
components in your life the right people
that gel with you then you feel as
though you're invincible it may be a
fallacy but you at least feel as though
you can you can take all that life has
to dish out that had like 106 dollars in
the bank and like i said i had to sell
my dog and things were not looking very
very good uh my 40 car had just blown up
so i was taking a bus to work and still
it didn't matter i wanted to stick with
it this guy as a young man had a dream
a dream to become a big movie star to
come to hollywood and become a great
director and producer and a writer and
all those kind of dreams he had of
course everyone told him it can't be
done but you know he wouldn't take no
for an answer and he moved across from
new york to los angeles to hollywood and
of course one day after struggling like
we all do in the beginning to get into
tv and in the movies he had this idea of
writing a script
and in longhand he wrote this script
which was rocky
the rest is history i truly believe and
people throw the word around dreams it's
all about dreams you know and by the way
dreams cost nothing they're free
the hard part is just keeping them going
and please keep them going because we're
here for one simple reason he believed
in the dream i believed in a dream and
our dreams come true and there's no
reason every one of yours can't either i
used to sit in this little apartment and
i was a room as a matter of fact the
room was so small i remember i was able
to open up the window and close the door
while sitting on the bed at the same
time it was like eight feet by eight
feet by nine feet but the one thing
about that room there was really very
little distraction so i would sit there
propped up in bed and i'd go out with my
big pan and legal pad and just start
writing these stories and most of them
were were very very trivial there was
something about the process of
unrealized dreams i was always brought
back to the subject because i think it's
one of the most enduring subjects and
one of the most
difficult
passages for people to accept that they
never were realized in their own
lifetime that they just didn't get that
shot so i decided it was a time to come
to california i went to california and i
moved in the valley and things weren't
going very very well there as a matter
of fact i had to credit sell my dog
because he was either
do that or he just was not going to be
very well fed around the house and then
one night
i went to see
muhammad ali fight chuck webb for one
brief moment
this
supposed stumble bomb
turned out to be magnificent in the fact
that he lasted and knocked the champion
down i said boy if this isn't a metaphor
for life his entire life crystallized at
that moment he will be remembered
for all eternity at least
among the fight fans he did something
extraordinary now that
that is probably what i need is a
catalyst for an idea a man who's going
to stand up to life
and take one shot
and maybe go the distance so i started
to write i first met uh bob shardoff and
irwin winkler and i believe i was there
on on a
casting call
so we're talking a little bit and i
guess i really wasn't right for the
acting part and on the way out
i said oh i don't know if it matters but
i do a little bit of writing he goes
really you've seen well he as well
bring it around i thought if i hadn't
stopped on the way out you know that's
why i tell all actors don't give up keep
talking eventually you might hit a nerve
somewhere and they go ah come on back
and
if they didn't say come on back or bring
it later and let's see what you've
developed
i wouldn't be sitting here so i have to
give incredible credit to their uh to
their insight and their patience and
they're willing to take a chance which
um
it doesn't exist much anymore
unfortunately originally when i brought
the script to them
they were fairly enthusiastic about it
the one thing they were not enthusiastic
about was me playing the part the story
about you not giving them the script
without agreeing to you starring in it
that that is true oh yeah definitely
it was just one of those crossroads
situations that every artist faces early
on go left go right and if you make the
wrong decision you sometimes regret it
forever and i just knew i wasn't a very
good student but i decided i always like
understood dialogue winner so i wrote
something that i know i could do that i
could feel good with and that could show
everything that is possible in my
repertoire it was one of those things
where you really roll the dice and it
paid off but it was a big long shot but
there was something inside of me that
that
you know this opportunity is never going
to come around and i really wasn't used
to money and i had no idea of what i
would be missing but
the temptation started to come forward
first it was 25 grand and a hundred
thousand dollars
i never heard of a hundred thousand
because i had like 106 dollars in the
bank and like i said i had to sell my
dog and things were not looking very
very good my 40 car had just blown up so
i was taking a bus to work and still it
didn't matter i wanted to stick with it
then it went up to 150 175 and it went
up to 250 000. now my head was starting
to spin and i thought all right you know
you've really managed poverty very well
you've got this down to a science you
really don't need much to live on i had
like sort of figured it out so i was not
in
any way
uh used to
to the good life i know in the back of
my mind if i
sell this script and it does very very
well i'm going to be very
very upset so this is one of those
things where you just roll the dice and
you fly by the proverbial seat of your
pants all right i gotta try it i gotta
just do it i may be totally wrong and
i'm gonna be taking a lot of people down
with me but i just believe in it i had
to teach myself early on
expect to fail
expect it
covet it welcome it it's going to happen
but don't it's not a permanent state the
most valuable thing you might have in
your life that you really don't pay
attention to especially when you're
young because you just feel
you have an abundance of it it's never
ending
time and as you get older you realize
time becomes
your currency when you realize there's
less runway up ahead than behind you
sometimes learn that too late so i'm
telling you people that you really have
to be very very very stingy with your
time don't waste it on people that
aren't like-minded don't waste it doing
things that you know
are not part of your dream plan
don't waste time being bitter which i
know i've been uh argumentative i
understand the meaning of hate because
in the end it's just waste your most
valuable asset time
we basically
are in a movie
from the time we're born
and then
when you get to be around 1820 you're
now the director of your movie which is
called life and i asked you knowing that
if you were in a movie of your own
making
would you be proud of the part you're
playing
i certainly wasn't and i took drastic
steps to to change all that
the point being
if you're producing this
film called you
make it the way you want to make it
you